u
dodocumentaire de Montréal.
NaNabi Alexandre Chartier.
- - Je m'appelle Gabor Szilasi.
G-G-A-B-O-R.
- - Gabor Szilasi est un des
phphotographes les plus importas
dudu Québec. Et c'est aussi
unun homme éminemment sympathiq.
♪♪  ♪  ♪
JOJOANNIE LAFRENIÈRE,
dodocumentariste
- - J'ai étudié en photo, puis
jeje suis tombée surur ses phot,
àà G Gabor, puis ça a été...
l'l'illumination totale parce qe
jeje retrouvais dans ses photos
totoute la poésie, mais aussi
l'l'humour, le respect.
JeJe trouvais qu'il y avait ça
dadans ses portraits, beaucoup.
- Durant quatre ans,
lala réalisatrice Joannie
LaLafrenièrere a accompagné Gab,
auaujourd'hui âgégé de 93 ans,
popour qu'il lui raconte sa vie
etet son destin exceptionnel.
GAGABOR SZILASI, photographe
- - Je suis arrivé à Q Québec
avavec mon pèrere. On est arrivs
cocomme réfugiés, dans les annés
5050, du communisme à B Budapes.
C Comme là, cette petite maiso,
esest-ce que ça existe encore?
- - À son arrivée au Québec,
ilil a parcouru la belle provine
popour la photographier
popour l'Office du film du Québ.
- - C'était vraiment le Québec
auaux portes de la modernité.
C'C'est comme si Gabor a capté
cecette transformation-là
ququi se faisait doucement.
- - Une collection de photos
ririches et précieuses
ququi racontent de manièrere
inincomparable un pan
dede notre histoire.
- - Oui, j'adore les gens.
PoPour moi, la photographie
c'c'était une bobonne façon de
rerencontrer les gens.
- - Durant des décennies, il a
phphotographié de grands artist,
auaussi bien que des quidams, ac
sesensibilité, humour et respec.
- - J'ai une approche
trtrès s optimiste, très s posie
lala vie. Je crois que les gens,
enen général, sont bons,
mamais il y a des méchants auss.
- - Gabor est né en 1928, donc,
ilil a connu la Deuxièmeme Guere
momondiale. Il y avavait quand e
dedes choses que j'ai découverts
auaussi au fil de nos rencontres
pupuis que je trouve qui étaient
imimportantes à a aborder.
JeJe pense que la résilience
ququ'il y a chez cet homme-là,,
sisi on comprend par quoi
ilil est passé, on comprend ausi
cecette résilience-là..
- - Ils nous ont attrapés
àà l la frontièrere.
- - Le film "Gabor" parle d'exi,
d'd'amour et d'amitié avec force
etet sensibilité.
♪♪  ♪  ♪
D Dans l'objectif de Gabor et
dadans celui de Joannie, les ges
sosont beaux à l l'intérieur
cocomme à l l'extérieur.
I Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
R R